um so this is jointed with Fedor
sandinsky and Joe Ru here we are hard at
work um three of us have actually never
been in the same room together this
is project um so when in this project
we're interested in matching with
aligned preferences let me explain what
this is so here's an example so you have
uh so it's two- sided matching two
populations X and Y and um the we we
form couples know one agent from X1
agent from Y and the utility that they
get is the
same so if X1 and y1 from a couple from
a pair then the utility that X1 gets and
the utility that y1 gets are the same so
here's an example where put the
utilities as a
matrix uh and um so if X1 forms a pair
with Y3 then both of them get
the8 so imagine you want to find the
stable matchings it's pretty obvious
that X1 and Y3 has to be together
otherwise there no blocking pair um so
once I realize that I I you know I form
that CLE I take them out of out of the
economy and I'm left with
X2 X3 and y1 Y two and then it's clear
that X3 and Y3 have to form a pair
otherwise they would block right and so
on okay so this gives me a very simple
way of understanding what the stable
matchings have to be in this type of
simple and environment okay so this is a
type of structure and preferences that
have a sense people don't think is
particularly interesting so I want to
tell you you're wrong if you think that
it's it is more interesting than you
think and we're actually not the first
ones to notice this is a uh paper that
actually been around for a while that uh
um that ferian Netherland wrote which
studies um this type of models with
aligned
preferences um so if you are curious uh
suppose instead what you try to do is
you look at the utilitarian um sum of
utilities which is what you would do if
this were an assignment problem then you
would match along the diagonals because
that keeps you higher Ware this is
clearly not what stability gives you so
one question you might be interested in
is what is the connection between these
two objects I we have something to say
about
that um okay so let me show you another
example to um um convince you that this
is indeed uh an interesting type of
structure so here's here's the example
so I'm going to look at um in this
example at infinite matching
markets so uh imagine you have two
populations of agents and the two
populations they are described by a
number on the real
line uh and so one of them will be
represented by one um uh measure mu on X
uh which is a subset of the real line
and another population is new and let's
say they both have a
density now the utility from a match
will be how close people are to each
other so let's imagine that you're each
agent is described by this know position
on the line and you know like wants to
be with like so people want to be with
people who are as as similar to them as
possible okay so very simple preferences
um so here's an example I have two
densities the red density and the blue
density and they happen to to have this
joint support in this
exam all right so what do the what do
the stable matchings look like
here I give you a few seconds to think
about people want to be with people who
are very similar to
them so I show you a picture so I put
the I took away the colors and I put the
what was it blue so the blue ones I put
pointing down just to just to make it
easier to see okay same densities but I
I just put one density pointing up the
other one pointing down okay so if you
think about the example I show you
before where there was a number eight
and it was obvious that the people that
generated eight had to be together here
you see that the people who are very
very you know who can be very close to
each other they have to be you know
match to each other other words they
would they would block right so what's
gonna happen is that I'm gonna match
these guys together these guys together
and these guys together and then I'm
gonna sort of imagine you could do this
sequentially then I'm going to start to
sort of move out and form couples that
are you know further and further away
from each other right so to start
matching these guys to each other and mo
move out all the time the same with the
blue ones the same with these green
couples except here you know the speed
because because these
densities have different heights in any
given interval there there are more of
these guys than there are of these guys
so therefore I'm gonna you know the the
speed at which I I move to the right
here is
faster can imagine that so after a while
it's going to look like this I'm
gonna I'm exhaust these guys I'm G to
reach the mid midpoint in which these
are going to be matched with these and
also some of these going to be match
over here and then I'm going to be left
with this left
overs that this sort of greedy uh
algorithm couldn't you know handled
anymore and then I would start to have
start to have to match people who have
very away from each
other so this is what the stable
matchings will look like is
AR um and so hopefully you think well
that that's actually pretty cool I
didn't know I didn't think that that um
it's interesting it's actually a
structural property that um uh that we
call no Crossing no so if you see none
of these arcs cross each
other and and this turns out to be a
general property whenever you're
thinking about matching on the real line
like we're doing
here and uh that's sort of part of what
I try to convince you that this is um if
you think about these matching markets
and you you think about them through the
lens of optimal transport which is you
seen in a moment um there there are
structur properties of um of the of the
stable matchings uh which you know we
can study in this way and and that are
interesting to to learn and to
understand here's another example just
to show you the difference between
stability and fairness it's a very very
simple example you have this density
this density again stability will match
these guys to each other and then when I
start to move out I get these
arcs but but this is you know very
unfair right because these people get
very high utility they're very M they're
much closely to each other these people
here are miserable they're matched to um
agents who are very different from them
but I could I could make everyone just
as happy keeping the distance between
any pair constant by matching them in
this
way so if you wanted so if you want
stability this is what you get if you
want to be fair this is what you
get there's something sorry to so this
is the knife edge case right it's very
well known in optimal transport you take
one distance you you if you do the
utilitarian
solution to take your vocabulary you get
two you show show the two you showed are
both optimal this is the one Cas has no
uniqueness no no no I know what you
let's talk about optimal later I don't
know what you mean by Optimal but but
they would have two
different
um give me a bit more time I'll show you
what what we what
anyway so quick overview what we do in
the paper uh so first of all iine
preferences I'm going to AR you're
interesting uh they emerge naturally in
some problems uh for example uh when
there is an objective notion of fit so
two agents get you know the same utility
maybe because there's some natural way
in which we talk about match quality and
then uh you know both sides care about
this match quality could be for example
um your think
about organ donations something like
that you care about you know how how
good is how good of a fit is this um
donor for this patient and things like
that and there is this objective notion
that is uh you know driving the
preferences um also matching with
transfers uh like the ones that Bernard
was talking about earlier today um so IM
matching with transfers you imagine that
when the agents are bargaining they're
also bargaining of over the over
transfers Al so you know for example the
marriage application you imagine that
when you're bargaining over you know
who's going to be your your um the
partner you're also bargaining with them
about the transfers uh but you might
imagine many situations in which you
can't commit to a transfer at the point
at which you're bargaining you know
after you got married then you know you
can't sort of um there's no contract
that says you know who's going to do the
dishes who's GNA and um and so you know
if if that happens then you can't you
can't think that um uh that every every
pair has you know sort of backward
inducts um you know what the outcome of
the internal bargan will be and then you
naturally get this type of
com um another reason we think this is
interesting is what I'll show you uh
next which is the connection to Optimal
transport which um shows that this ideas
of stability that uh and and also
fairness that are naturally connected to
some op optimization problems at least
in an approximate sense um and so we can
study it on through the lens of optimal
transport and that will give you some
insight for for example this structural
um properties of stable matchings that I
was uh there will be a tension with
between stability and fairness that we
we will see emerge from this transport
um I will'll be able to talk about
approximate utilitarian welfare
maximization which is maybe what Bernard
is thinking about but but here the
objective will actually be different
from the ones here you will see this in
a in a
minute another thing that we think is
really important is that this results
extend beyond the two sided matching
problem to the many sided matching
problems um in which existence is
generally not guaranteed so this sort of
man woman child problem which is known
to have non-existence
of but under the assumption of aligned
preferences then you know stability does
exist and you know many of our results
extend to the settings and then allows
us to capture um problems like for
example te information Supply chains
problems also you can encode organ some
you know certain organization problem in
this in this I won't have time to talk
about that today
but when the paper is written that will
be still a
bit okay so this is the model um like
you saw in the examples I will be uh
interested in um markets which are not
necessarily finite so uh so one
advantage of this is that we can talk
about very general magic markets and you
know in particular we can talk about
matching markets that are not um that
are not necessarily finite um uh so a
matching problem is a tble x mu y new u
and v where X and Y are polish spaces so
these are complete meable separable uh
spaces with a natural measurability
structure uh mu will be some measure
which is finite on X and the new is
another finite measure on new and in
fact the measure on the two are the same
so this should be a new not a mu
okay uh and then u and v are two
functions uh which are going to be the
two utility
functions
any questions about the
mod so for example the
um an example of this is the the example
that I was showing you about before
where you have the agents were situated
on the rear line and you have some
density that describes the two
populations that's
that's okay so uh what's a matching a
matching
is a finite measure on the product space
which respects the two marginals so if I
look at the margin alone X it's equal to
mu and the margin alone Y is equal to
new that's a matching and Pi of mu new
uh is the set of all
matchings stability what does stability
mean so matching Pi is Epsilon stable
I'm going to work with approximations
here um
if when I draw a
couple um X1 y1 and then independent to
draw another
couple X2 Y2 according to the matching
okay so X1 is y1 are you know in a sense
matched in pi and X2 and Y2 are in a
sense matched in draw two couples
according to this uh is pi and I draw
them independently and then I take the X
component of Y and the Y component of
the other and I I check whether they
from a blocking
pair okay and then what would would it
mean for it to be a block imp pair would
it would mean that the this mismatch is
higher than so X1 gets higher utility
here with Y2 than with y1 and you know
Y2 gets higher utility here than what
they get with
this okay so if at this one of these
holds and I and I have an
Epsilon go in my favor
here okay so hopefully this looks
familiar enough that that you believe
that this in this you know potential
infinite World this is a reasonable
notion of
stability okay so this is the definition
of what however if you don't like it I
have an equivalent one um this one
requires u and v to be
continuous so if there are continuous
functions then I'm matching is Epsilon
stable if whenever it takes when I take
two couples in the support of
Pi then um if I if I Mis if I mix match
them then they don't want to
block little LMA shows that the two
things
are okay anyway
I hopefully this is makes sense as the
natural notion of stability
um all right so we're going to focus on
aligned preferences so what does it mean
for preferen to be aligned well they're
they're aligned if the utilities are the
same and B are the
same that case this inequality simplify
and a matching is stable if whenever I
take the two couples X1 y1 and X2 and
Y2
um um the the inequality the utility of
the mismatched of the potential block
imp pair doesn't exceed the largest of
these
two right if it were to be bigger then
X1 would want would want to block and Y2
would want to block because the utility
that X1 gets is described by U so this
utility will be higher than what X1 gets
with y1 and at the same time the utility
Y2 gets which is also described by u in
this case because of the Align
preferences is higher than what Y2 gets
when they're match with X2
okay so uh with the line preferences the
um stability requirements
uh collapse to this
inequality okay
simp all
right okay that's stability what about
equalitarianism this I want to get at
fairness as well as as well as stability
so here's what we mean by by being we
want to be fair so for each matching I
can look at the the the smallest utility
of a couple gets in the matching okay
the least utility in the support of
Pi all
right and and uh
if if this minimum doesn't exist I can
replace it with an INF that's
okay so this is the this is the least
utility that that sort of match couple
gets um
matching is
aarian if it maximizes this objective if
it maximizes the smallest utility at any
anyone in the in the support
of and again I we need to relax things
so I would say it's Epsilon Delta
galarian if there's a subset s of
couples which has probability at least
one minus
Delta such that everyone in that set is
getting utility at least the the
minimum possible the the one that solve
this problem minus
Epsilon so if I if I solve this
problem that's Pi
star then I I give myself an
Epsilon everyone in s gets at least that
that
much the set s is large in the sense
that it has probability at least oneus
that's what eps
okay that's that's
Del all right so we know what stability
means we know what um it means to be
egalitarian all right so I I'm GNA claim
that this has a connection to Optimal
transport uh so it is up not transport
so it's U this
um it's a sort of theory um that's
a special case of linear param
um has been studied a lot and which
focuses on
on matchings um so uh if a function C uh
that Maps X cross Y into R is called a
cost function uh then the optimal
transport problem that is associated to
C and to the two populations mu and new
is a problem of finding a matching that
minimizes
cost
minimize the cost of any company
I um now I want to come up with a
particular cost function that I think um
will end up hopefully you'll see end up
make making
sense might not be what what you expect
this something slightly funny about it
but but it
does so consider this C cost function
for um so the cost Associated to X and Y
is 1 / Alpha * 1 minus E to the alpha
time
U okay so this might looked um looks
strange but if you if you think about it
for for a minute it maybe it starts to
make sense so think first about the case
what happens when Alpha is
positive remember we're going to be
studying this optimal transport problem
that minimizes cost
so when Alpha is positive I'm minimizing
cost and this is the cost of X and
Y so when Alpha is positive I can ignore
Alpha take it out of here I'm still
minimizing what's left and this one is a
constant I can minim forget about that
and there a minus in front of it but
then a minus in front of a minimization
problem turns it into a maximization
problem so you can think about this
problem then that's about maximizing e
to the alpha
U but that's like Max maximizing a a
convex function of
U taking Alpha to be large I can I can
make it you know very
convex so that's what happens when Alpha
is positive and large now imagine I take
Alpha to be negative when Alpha is
negative again keep in mind it's
negative and take it
out now throw away the the one again
which is now one never mind take it out
but now this um minus became a plus
because it was it was negative so I'm
minimizing this thing but more
comfortable thinking about maximum we
just talked about maximum so let's let
put the minus back and turn the minan
into a Max then what are we doing we're
maximizing again minus E to the alpha U
where Alpha is negative so now I'm
maximizing a concave function here and
then I'm going to make this very concave
but taking the U with the alpha to be
log so that's what uh that's what this
is trying to do um and it actually the
this particular functional form uh
doesn't doesn't matter you there a way
of generalizing this will which I might
mention later
I okay so then we get these two
theorems so remember the optimal
transport problem is the one here
and minimizing cost and then I have
these two theorems one for stability one
for fairness when Alpha is positive any
solution to this optimal transport
problem will be Epsilon stable where
Epsilon is log two over
Alpha okay so by taking Alpha positive
and large enough I can get you know the
the the stability requirement to be
tied okay I can make the to this
one all right
right why does this make sense well
remember this corresponds to maximizing
this function that are going to make it
be very
convex and think about this idea in the
example I talked about in the beginning
where we started by worrying about these
guys that generate a lot of utility the
eight in in The Matrix so by making this
objective very very convex going to make
sure that put a lot of weight on those
very high utility generating
couples that's a that's a rough
intuition for why this generates Epsilon
stable uh the contrary if we look at uh
negative Alphas then any solution will
be Epsilon Delta legal
itarian where uh for any Epsilon I can
make the Delta small enough by taking
the alpha to
be remember that the Delta so the the
the probability of s which was all the
people were guaranteeing a certain
minimum Lev utility tool was one minus
Delta so by making Delta small and
making sure that we're guaranteeing this
every utility to a lot of
people
okay yeah and it doesn't yeah so you can
generalize this to other cost function
doesn't need to be the one that I show
you all right so there is an interest in
um the existence of stable matchings in
infinite markets so we can get that a
Cory um so if you look
at uh if you if you look at all the
solutions to the transportation problem
with positive Alpha and you take a
sequence of solutions as Alpha goes to
Infinity uh and you collect here all the
limit points of this way of proceeding
there actually by the way even though X
and Y may not be compact there is there
is a there's enough compactness in here
in the optimal transport problem due to
the fact that the marginals are
fixed that this type of um that this
type of thing makes sense so for example
you can get existence of automa
Transport problems um even without
without assuming
compa um so
uh so if if I take my U and I
reparameterize it um to make sure it's
bounded which which you can do ways um
and then uh and and then you you'll um
you look at this set of limit points uh
it is uh a
non-empty uh convex uh it's a weekly
closed um set of of stable Magics so
this gives us existence and it gives us
a way of in some sense finding um stable
matchings for
this and I
don't I don't have okay so let me tell
you this I was hoping to show you a
little bit of the proof but okay so let
me tell you about the connection with
utilitarianism and um let me just let me
just State the result maybe this is what
mind um so for the if you're looking at
the utilitarian welfare of the
maxim matching and you look at the
problem of
maximizing then actually any Epson
stable matching um satisfies this W
guarantee I canchi at
least
sorry
the
uh
Howes are comparable
St I matching can
be
most
is some
sense that's a good question
I you yeah I'm sure you can generate
stable matchings which are very unfair
you can maybe get them to be as unfair
as
you set up I I have the feeling that
they might be the most
to because of assertive
magic uh I don't know what you mean by
assortative every likes uh likes of
them can we yeah I mean that
that that is that's true in the example
I show in the
beginning but in general there's no
notion of people being similar to each
other so in my model
um X and this spaces X and
Y there there's no reason why it makes
sense to of comparing how similar people
are to each other just give a simple
example uh everybody might
produc number total product
multiplication of the yeah yeah yeah
yeah so I mean yeah for sure you can you
can create
examples which are where this becomes
assortative but in general this has no
connection to assortativeness
um but but there is still a structural
property that is relevant which is that
actually makes sense in our
setting may I would mention that so this
is a very standard idea of transport in
other areas which isly
monity
so even though I can't compare X and Y I
can talk about the cost of X and Y so uh
a subset of the product X and Y is
called cyclically monotone if if I form
sequences of
pairs and I and I look at the sum of the
cost of the
pairs okay and I and I shift what one of
the elements of the pair by
one and I pick the pair so that so that
this is so so the summation is sort of
mod M no so that um y n + one equals
y1 then this inequality has to
hold you may familiar with this notion C
monity it shows up a mechanism the sign
many other
setting compx anal is very important but
this property of cyclic
monotonicity um is true of the support
of any solution to the optimal transfer
problem so the any solution of the op
transport problem has to be supported in
a
c and this is a structural property that
we can talk about so this um this is
where the no Crossing property comes
from in the in the one dimensional
set and then uh yeah so so skip the
pro maybe I will just mention this very
quickly so um guess
either people um don't care as much as I
thought they did or um you're not um
you're not
um not so many Economist in the room but
but usually we are skeptical of this
kind of um uh Cardinal uh
utility um so question is um if you give
me a market with ordinary preferences of
of the
agents over Partners when can we come up
with um a function that works the way U
Works uh fuction works and that is uh
you can problem that has been studied in
different settings and it's about the
existence of a potential for this
problem
so so anyway we have a theorem that
shows you when such a object exists and
there are some topological assumptions
that are needed and some continuity
assumption that are need of
thein which I'm not going to show you
but but the main property that you need
so substantive property is the ecity of
this type of um um of of the preferences
so when you when you think that X and Y
Must have the same
objective then if you if you move if you
fix X you move from one partner of x y y
Prime you fix y Prime you move from X to
X Prime and then from X Prime you move
from y Prime to Y double Prime and so on
each time improving in that agent
preferences um you shouldn't be able to
form a cycle if there existed a
potential so that property ends up also
being sufficient for the existence of
potential as long as this additional
more technical
assumption anyway I'm out of time and I
uh sorry I take questions and chat about
it at the reception which is next door
Simon Cy provides for
[Music]
us
so you're not sming yet